[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing a rather
compelling Theory pertaining to the
defense against the dark arts posting at
Hogwart school I first saw this theory
on Reddit so shout out to Word hammer on
the HP subreddit for the
inspiration defense against the dark art
is a core subject taught at Hogwarts
that purportedly teaches students how to
defend themselves against dark magic
creatures and curses though I'm not sure
this subject has been particularly
successful in this regard the curriculum
covers a wide range of topics including
recognizing and repelling dark creatures
identifying and countering curses and
learning protective spells but for as
long as Harry attended Hogwarts and
actually for many decades prior the
subject had a particularly High turnover
rate scratch that a ludicrously high
turnover rate every single year that
Harry attended Hogwarts he had a
completely different Professor that
taught the subject in an entirely
different way as you can imagine this
was pretty disruptive to the learning
process and who could be responsible for
such a mess why Lord Voldemort of course
this is explained to Harry by Dumbledore
oh he definitely wanted the defense
against the dark Art's job said
Dumbledore the aftermath of our little
meeting proved that you see we've never
been able to keep a defense against the
darkarts teacher for longer than a year
since I refused the post to Lord
Voldemort and it all dates back to young
Tom Riddle's graduation from Hogwarts
shortly after completing his studies Tom
Riddle expressed his desire to become
the defense against the dark arts
professor at his Alma matter partially
driven by his love for the school and
partially driven by his fascination with
the dark ey
and he didn't waste any time quickly
submitting an application to then
Headmaster Armando dippit after some
time dippet ended up refusing Riddle's
application citing his age but did
encourage him to reapply in the future
if he was still interested more than two
decades later riddle emerged as the
enigmatic and notorious Lord Voldemort
seeking an opportunity to return to
Hogwarts Voldemort once again pursued
the coveted defense against s Art's
position however this time alus
Dumbledore had assumed the role of
Headmaster recognizing Voldemort's dark
intentions Dumbledore staunchly rejected
his application despite Voldemort's
ulterior motives of using the
application as a pretext to conduct
research on dark magic recruit followers
and conceal one of his haw rers he was
enraged by the denial of his return to
the school after his denial Voldemort
sought Vengeance by jinxing the position
ensuring that from that point onward no
one could maintain the defense against
the dark arts post for more than one
year and as far as conventional
understanding of the Harry Potter Story
Goes everyone has always accepted this
fact at face value no one can hold a
position for more than a year and that's
about all there is to it there's no
explanation for why one year or how one
year is actually been forced which makes
me wonder how is it this Jinx actually
works we the outcome but have very
little information on the process today
I want to discuss a compelling Theory
which adds a layer of depth to
Voldemort's nefarious Jinx perhaps
suggesting that the Jinx is far more
Sinister than meets the eye in essence
the Sinister Theory posits that whoever
occupies the data position is destined
to be confronted by his or her worst
fears from the moment they sign the
dotted line and occupy the position this
fate becomes inevitable going through
the list of data professors that
occupied the role during Harry's time at
Hogwarts let's take a closer look ginus
quirrel ginus quirrel was an English
halfblood wizard born sometime in the
1960s quirrel was a highly unusual and
delicate but talented student and was
teased profusely at school making the
anxious quirrel even more anxious he
also had feelings of inadequacy which
led to him taking a particular interest
in the dark arts a highly complicated
and dangerous field of magic that could
perhaps gar a quirrel the attention and
respect that he always longed for in
1990 after teaching for several years as
the Muggle studied professor at Hogwarts
gal became shall we say fed up this led
to him taking a year-long sabatical in
order to gain firsthand experience in
the field however Coral's real objective
was to find Lord Voldemort fueled by his
intense need to be recognized and
acknowledged gell set off with the
belief that if he was the one to find
Voldemort he would be praised by all of
the Wizarding World and find Voldemort
he did however things didn't go exactly
according to plan as he was easily
manipulated and controlled by Voldemort
Voldemort recounts just how easy quirrel
was to manipulate a wizard young foolish
and gullible wandered across my path in
the forest I'd made my home oh he seemed
the very chance I'd been dreaming of for
he was a teacher at Dumbledore's school
he was easy to bend to my will
he brought me back to this country and
after a while I took possession of his
body to supervise him closely as he
carried out my orders for as long as
qurl was alive his greatest desire was
to be recognized he was intelligent
capable and more than willing to put the
work in but for some reason he was never
properly acknowledged contrary to this
quell's greatest fear was to never be
recognized living out a life where his
contributions to society were
continually swept under the rug
after being overpowered by Voldemort
airel was forced to face this fear head
on under the Dark Lord's control he was
devalued used and then thrown away the
worst part of it all was that his death
was never even investigated the Fate was
not kind to the poor misguided quirrel
and he ended up facing his greatest
fears in the worst way possible gilderoy
lockheart in adolescence lockart was a
clever good-looking boy and when he
realized quite early on that he was
magical it only went to his head
inflating his already massive ego even
further in 1975 lockart began attending
Hogwart School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry when he first walked through
the doors of the school he was met with
disappointment as he came to the
crushing realization that at a school
for witches and wizards he was just
another magical young boy in the Muckle
world gildroy was exceptional but here
he didn't stand out and that's all he
ever longed for in adulthood we are
introduced to a lockart that that's
ostentatious egotistical and quite
frankly delusional over the course of
his life he capitalized on the
achievements of genuinely powerful
witches and wizards by quite deviously
implementing memory charms that made
them forget altogether what they had
done with no one to lay claim to these
accomplishments and no one to refute
that it wasn't lockart who had achieved
them he claimed them for himself which
leads me to Lockhart's biggest fear
being exposed as nothing exceptional you
see Lockhart's whole existence was a
facade an attempt at conveying to the
outside world that he was more amazing
than he really was and during his time
as D Professor Lockhart's biggest fear
finally came true when he was properly
exposed Remis Lupin to me Remis Lupin
was unquestionably the best defense
against the dark arts Professor but that
still didn't give him any purchase with
regards to staying on past his first
year in the role perhaps one of the most
difficult aspects of lupin's existence
was that he suffered from like anthropy
a magical Affliction that transforms
witches Wizards into werewolves Lupin
was afflicted with this disease at a
very young age after being infected by
fenri greyback which meant that he had
to deal with it for most of its
existence and perhaps one of lupin's
greatest fears was that he a was exposed
as a werewolf mainly due to the stigma
towards werewolves in witing society and
B that he would lose control in his
werewolf form and risk hurting those
closest to him and while serving as
Professor for defense against the dark
arts Lupin faced both of these scenarios
in a relatively short period of time B
crunch junor fake moody in the 1994 to
1995 school year Barty cratch Jr
disguised as Professor alist Moody via
po potion took on the role of data
Professor interestingly despite being an
active Death Eater Barty cratch Jr did a
fairly good job of teaching the subject
however while acting as the Imposter
Professor he was ultimately forced to
conf front numerous challenging
situations that ultimately led to the
manifestation of his fears firstly in
order to maintain his disguise he had to
kill his own father bat senior who was a
prominent figure in the ministry of
magic and staunchly opposed to Voldemort
this act demonstrated his loyalty to
Voldemort but also highlighted the fear
and Desperation that drove him
additionally body cratch Junior's
involvement in the tri was in tournament
which was manipulated to Aid Voldemort's
Resurrection ction led to him missing
the significant moment when his master
returned this missed opportunity likely
intensified his fear and anxiety about
his own standing with Voldemort and the
consequences if he failed to deliver
body crunch Junior's greatest fears
revolved around failing in his mission
to serve Voldemort and the consequences
that would come with it he was known for
his unwavering commitment to the dark
lord and he would have been afraid of
disappointing Voldemort or facing his
wrath if he were to make a mistake or fa
fail in any way and at the end of the
same school year when B Crouch Jr was
finally exposed as an impostor he was
subjected to the dementor's kiss a fate
that eradicated his soul this encounter
with the dementa further solidified the
theme of fear in his storyline leaving
him devoid of any hope or identity
Dolores Umbridge Dolores umbridge's
tenure as the defense against the dark
arts Professor was marked by her strict
and oppressive teaching methods
appointed by the ministry magic
umbridge's primary aim was to control
the curriculum and ensure that the
ministry's propaganda was enforced while
her time as the data Professor did not
typically involve facing her fears it
did bring about challenging situations
that revealed her true nature and
ideology umbridge's fear was not related
to personal vulnerabilities or past
traumas but rather a fear of losing
control the fear of anything she
considered chaotic or outside of her
Authority furthermore Umbridge was
incredibly prejudiced she loathed any
and all kinds of magical creatures and
held a certain amount of disdain for
muggleborn
ultimately Umbridge has her Authority
completely destroyed then Falls victim
to half breeds and creatures well
because she was deceived by muggleborn
ouch Harry Potter though not an official
defense against the dark arts Professor
Harry Potter did covertly teach the
subject to his peers behind closed doors
during umbridge's rule over Hogwarts
at this point in time Dumbledore's Army
is formed and Harry teaches his friends
the ways of the petronis charm in the
room of requirement and as it would
appear not even Harry who unofficially
taught the subject was exempt from
Voldemort's curse in this same year
Harry's relationship with Cho implodes
he's caught by Umbridge as a result of
his most hated rival Draco and he even
ends up losing the closest thing to a
parent he had left sirious having lost
his parents at a very young age I think
that Harry's greatest fear was feeling
alone in the world devoid of friends and
family at this point in the story I'd
argue that Harry had a closer
relationship with Sirius than anyone
else largely due to the connection with
his parents Snape zah Snape became the
defense against the dark arts Professor
during Harry's 6th year at Hogwarts in
theory SRA Snape was the perfect defense
against the dark arts teacher he had a
profound understanding of both sides of
the magical spectrum and knew more about
the darkarts than most making him the
perfect candidate to teach students
defense however not even Snape who vied
for the data teaching position for so
many years seemed to be exempt from
Voldemort's Wicked curse it was in this
same school year that Snape had to begin
taking action with regards to his
perceived allegiances Snape was a bad
guy turned a good guy and that's
confirmed later on but for a while it's
a little unclear what side he's truly on
at the end of of the school year Snape
is forced to choose his side ruining his
reputation with those he respects even
if it was mainly just for the Optics
Snape's deepest fear was that he would
fail to fulfill his promise to protect
Lily's son Harry due to his own past
mistakes Central to this responsibility
was his partnership with Dumbledore the
only person who truly understood snap's
underlying motives ironically in the
same year Snape found himself faced with
the daunting task of killing Dumbledore
this unimaginable act would have
undoubtedly left Snape feeling
overwhelmingly scared and isolated in
his internal turmoil Amicus Caro the
caros electo and Amicus took up postings
as professors during Harry's 7th year at
Hogwarts in a time when Voldemort's
influence had taken hold of the school
their appointment was part of the death
eater's plan to indoctrinate students
with dark magic and suppress any form of
resistance
teaching not only allowed the caros to
spread their Twisted ideology but also
exposed them to situations that forced
them to confront their own fears firstly
as Death Eaters the caros were fervently
loyal to Voldemort witnessing the fall
of the dark lord as Harry Potter and his
allies grew stronger in their fight
against evil would have been a major
blow to their beliefs and an encounter
with their deepest fear the potential
loss of their Dark Lord's power and
influence furthermore their actions as
professors aligned with Voldemort's
oppressive regime inevitably led to
their downfall after Voldemort's defeat
the caros were captured by the Order of
the Phoenix and sent to aaban the prison
they had managed to avoid until then
this turn of events forced them to
confront the fear and despair of losing
their freedom and facing the
consequences of their actions in a cruel
twist of fate Harry Potter who had often
been a target of the Caro's cruelty
retaliated by using the cruciat curse on
Amicus when he spat insultingly at
Professor mcgonagal this act provided a
taste of their own medicine causing the
cars to experience the pain and
suffering that they had inflicted on
others this served as a moment of
Reckoning forcing them to confront the
fear and anguish they had willingly
inflicted on their victims closing
thoughts Voldemort's curse on the
defense against the dark arts data
position can be seen as a direct
response to the insult of his rejection
believing himself to be the most
qualified candidate for the role
Voldemort designed the curse to compel
any other contenders to demonstrate
their Superior suitability the curse
ultimately concludes when Voldemort dies
not due to the general rule that curses
end with the death of their Caster but
rather because he himself no longer has
the opportunity to assume the position
and that's it for this video what do you
think and you ever wondered how this
curse works please leave a comment down
below also if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to
[Music]
live